what's up believe nation so I'm curious
if you grow which YouTube channels do
you guys watch daily so got an alert
saying that I was in a video from one of
my fans and I went to go check out the
video and it's a cool video it's about
her entire morning routine and we'll
link it up below so you guys can check
it out but I wanted to include one
section of it where she included my
channel and another person's on her
daily list of things that she checks out
first thing I do it's taking my iPad and
checking on my YouTube subscriptions and
seizing new videos so that I can watch
motivational videos when I get ready in
the morning one essential part of my
morning routine is Evan Carmichael
channel because of the motivational
content he puts out and for lifestyle
things I love to follow
Kelly Nicholson I will link those
channels below so I'm curious for you
guys what YouTube channels do you watch
on a daily basis like you can't live I
guess you can live but you know you
don't want to live without that channel
on a regular basis what is it that
you're consuming I think of it for me on
a daily basis a daily basis the only
channel that I watch on a daily basis is
my own if I look in consistent basis
like at least weekly I'm looking at Gary
Vaynerchuk I'm looking at Lewis Howes
I'm looking at recently Breakfast Club
some of the interviews are interesting
and then some League of Legends channels
but I think from a business entrepreneur
angle that's it mine Gary Vee Lewis
Howes and Breakfast Club and I'm curious
for you guys who are you watching what
are you watching
first daily most important daily what
YouTube channel do you watch every
single day and then if you don't have
any then every week at least you're
watching one video per week leaving the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out learn more about you what
you're watching now so maybe discover
some channels for myself that I haven't
before so link that up thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you hope
you continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
[Music]